Sammy, are you there?
>> No, I'm here. I'm here. Can y'all hear
me?
>> Yep. You're a Muslim.
>> I am not a Muslim and I'm not a
Christian.
>> So, what in the world brought you to
this platform?
>> So, it's funny. I I look at the uh the
title, it says Islam verse Christianity.
I think neither is true. I think Judaism
is true.
>> Oh, okay. Judaism is true. What's true
about Judaism?
>> I mean, you guys don't you don't really
disagree with that because honestly,
Islam and Christianity are a lot based
on Judaism. Judaism, the the Torah.
>> It depends on what Judaism you're
talking about.
>> We disagree with the Orthodox Judaism of
today.
>> What's that? What do you mean about
>> We disagree with the Orthodox Judaism of
today.
>> Why is that?
>> Because it's not what was actually
taught in the Old Testament.
>> Give me an example. Give me a reason why
you think that was unorthodox.
>> Yeah. An example that they teach that
the Messiah uh would not be unal alive
for sins.
>> Would not be unalived for sins. So, what
is your proof that the Messiah
will be unal alive for sins in the
Hebrew Bible? And if you think that that
would exist in the New Testament, then
why why would the New Testament trump
the original? Why would God change his
mind? How could
>> it? It's it exists in both. I mean, so
it's obviously going to be in your ass
misinterpretation of Isaiah 53.
>> Yeah. Just just to be clear, Sammy,
you're not you're not talking with
Muslims. You're talking about the
Christians. We don't say that the Old
Testament's corrupted. Um, and whatever
disagrees with the New Testament, that's
that's what's corrupted. Whatever agrees
with the New Testament, that's good to
go. We're not Muslims. We don't pick and
choose. We don't cherrypick. We believe
in all of God's revelation. So, it goes
hand in hand.
>> Oh, yeah. So, who is Isaiah 53 talking
about?
>> Isaiah 53 is talking about the Jewish.
If you look at the entire if you read
the entire chapter, especially if you
read in the original Hebrew, it's
talking about the nation of Israel is a
um is a suffering servant as
even till today Jews are being
persecuted. Jews are being um uh all the
programs, the Holocaust, it's talking
about the Jewish people.
>> Does that heal us? Does does that heal
us? The fact that they're being
persecuted, does that heal us? I think
that the uh the point of that passage is
that through our suffering you'll you'll
be healed. Meaning we have a a verse
that through your
which means and through your blood you
shall live and through your blood you
shall live. that that has to do with uh
circumcision where blood comes out and
other other sufferings that atone for
our sins not necessarily someone else
that dies for our sins. I I love
Christians but I I don't agree. So the
issue is when it says by his stripes,
who's the his there?
>> His it's it's like for example, if you
look in the Song of Songs um written by
Solomon the king purported to be the
wisest of all um it's talking about a
woman it's why would such a holy man
Solomon talk about a a woman a a nice
looking woman is he and how would that
be included?
>> I was asking a question when it says by
his stripes who is it his? I'm
answering. So, so when it when it talks
about God marrying the woman, it means
God marrying all who follow God's way.
Um, and so God is essentially we're in a
a loving relationship with God. And so
God's not talking about a woman. God is
talking about
>> um anyone who So that man that we're
talking about in Isaiah is not a person
that comes out afterwards, which would
purported to be the Messiah.
>> Not answered yet. By his stripe, who is
the his?
>> What verse are you talking about?
>> But he was wounded for our
transgressions. He was bruised for our
iniquities. The chastise chastisement
for peace was upon him. And by his
stripes, who's the his?
>> That's I I'm assuming the Jews.
>> Okay. So, by his stripes, his is
referring to the Jews. So, by his
stripes, we Who's the we now?
>> Good question. I'm looking it up right
now. Isaiah 53. Which verse?
>> Verse five.
For the one who made you, whose name is
God of hosts, will espouse you. The Holy
One of Israel, who is called God of all
the earth, will redeem you. What? What?
What am I missing? Oh, I'm in Isaiah 54.
My bad. My bad. I want I want to go into
another category. It's it's one thing
also to believe that Jesus um was the
Messiah or is the Messiah or whatever,
but what what makes you believe that he
is now become part of God?
>> Wait, can you answer the question?
>> Okay.
He was wounded because of our sins,
crushed because of our iniquities. He
bore the chastise that made us whole.
And by his bruises we were healed.
>> So who so the his we already refer to is
the Jews. So now who's the we?
>> Good question.
I got to know this. I got to know this
better. But let's say for example and by
the way just because someone
>> the only answer to this is that it's the
only answer to this is that it's
somebody who is representing right who's
the savior who's taking the punishment
that brings healing to Israel. It's not
Israel itself. Israel is being saved in
this context. They're not the savior.
>> So, I would go try to figure that out
and do some research.
>> Okay. So, well, why would you assume
that someone is just because someone
dies for your sins doesn't mean that
doesn't make them God.
>> Okay. So, well,
>> yeah. The the point the point that Nick
said, Nick said one thing, right?
Orthodox Judaism is false because it
rejects this this atonement sacrifice of
the Messiah while we and you said show
show us that in the scripture and so
we're showing you Isaiah 53 literally
talks about the Messiah being the
atoning sacrifice for our sins. So do
you affirm this now?
>> I'm I'm I'm saying hypothetically
speaking let's say this is affirmed. Let
they no no not hypothetically accord we
just read the scripture you and I
>> can we affirm from the scripture from
just reading the text that the Messiah
the suffering servant atones for the
sins for our sins
>> that can that can definitely I can
definitely agree with that I can agree
that a messiah can atone for the sins of
the people we we
>> orthodox Judaism rejects that so
>> you know that's not true there are a lot
of there are a lot of if you look in the
Talmud there are a lot of stories about
rabbis getting uh um
>> rabbis aren't the Messiah.
>> It doesn't say in Isaiah 53 that this
person is necessarily the Messiah.
>> Who who is the one that comes and atones
for the sins of Israel and saves them
and bears their sins and iniquities and
brings righteousness of God and
knowledge of God to them. Who is that?
>> Does it say that it was a Messiah? It
could. It could be. I'm not saying it's
not.
>> All right. So,
just to be clear, just just to go back
cuz cuz this is a roll off of 52. When
we read 52 um at the end of it talk
where it first talks about the suffering
servant. This is actually where it
begins. It says behold my servant shall
act wisely. He shall be high and lifted
up and shall be exalted as many were
astonished at you. His appearance was so
marred beyond human symbols meaning he
was beaten beyond human uh complex uh
human resemblance and his form beyond
that of the children of mankind. So
shall he sprinkle many nations kings. So
sprinkling many nations with that
language is of the altar language,
right? The atoning uh the sacrificial
language when you you know unal alive
bull sprinkle his blood on the altar. So
shall he sprinkle many nations. Kings
shall shut their mouths because of him.
For that which has not been told of them
they see and that which they have not
heard they understand. So it's talking
about an exalt that this servant who
suffers but then gets exalted and is a
ruler and uh is honored with God.
>> And and to his point by the way you
bring up Tarums Tarum Jonathan on Isaiah
42:13 which is the same servant says
behold my servant the Messiah shall
prosper. So even the Tarums affirm that
this is talking about the Messiah. Well,
I I'm the commentaries that I'm reading
um don't mention that it's the Messiah.
And even if it was the Messiah, how do
you know that Jesus himself was the
Messiah? Maybe it's
>> that's a whole different still to come.
>> We can get Yeah, we can get into that.
That's a whole different question.
>> So, I'm granting you this already. I'm
granting you this.
>> I'm saying if you grant us this, then
you grant us Orthodox Judaism is false.
>> Why?
>> Because Orthodox Judaism rejects the
Messiah will come and be unall alive for
the sins of the people.
>> I don't know if that's true. I don't
know if that's true. Where do you say
that? That's true.
>> You just read You just read it.
>> Yeah, we literally That's what we just
went over.
>> No. Where do Where do you see that? Orth
Orthodox Jews don't believe that the
that the Messiah will die one day?
>> Wait, so you Wait, so let me get this
straight. As an Orthodox Jew, do you
believe the Messiah will come and be
unal alive for our sins?
>> Let's Okay, I do. Yes,
>> you don't. Show me, bro. Show me any
rabbi that says that.
>> You You just He just changed his
position today. You you just you just
wait Sammy you just you just came
correct
>> Sammy just hold on a second you just
came to that belief today right you just
changed your position to that when you w
when you walked in here did you believe
that the Messiah is going to come and be
unal alive for our sins? Did you did you
walk in this live stream believing that?
>> The answer to that is that it was up for
discussion. I knew that that was going
to be up for discussion.
>> Sammy, that's not that's not that's not
that's not my question. Did you walk
into this live stream with that belief?
Why is that relevant, Sam?
>> Why does that matter? Do you know about
the
>> You're acting like a Muslim now, man. I
usually kick the Muslims by now because
they're being dishonest and not
answering direct questions, brother.
>> Okay, I'll answer the The truth is that
No. No, I didn't.
>> Thank you. That's not hard. That's But
that wasn't hard at all.
>> But I also have another question for
you.
>> Wait, before you ask another question,
focus on the thought that's being
presented. So when you walked into this
into this live stream as an Orthodox
Jew, you did not have the belief as an
Orthodox Jew because you're an Orthodox
Jew and what you've learned within
Orthodoxy of Judaism that the Messiah
was going to come and be unallalied for
our sins. You did not believe that. Now
you do because two Christians showed you
the scripture.
>> Fine. Okay. But why does that prove that
Christianity is true? I don't get why.
>> Let's let's let's at least pause here.
It proves that rabbitic Judaism is
false. Then we can go into showing why
this shows that Christianity is true. So
can we agree there that rabbitic Judaism
is false so far?
>> No. Because I don't I don't get that
jump. I don't know. Rabb rabbis have not
said to me, I've met hundreds of them.
They have not said that the Messiah will
not die. We're looking to get the
Messiah. We're praying every day that
the Messiah should come.
>> The Messiah won't die. We're saying that
there is no Jewish rabbi that's going to
say that the Messiah is going to be the
atonement for our sins.
>> No.
>> Do you believe that the Messiah Do you
believe Orthodox Judaism teaches the
Messiah will atone for our sins?
>> It it's it's it's Yeah. Why not?
>> No, they don't, bro.
>> Why not? Why is that such
>> Orthodox Judaism? But they don't believe
that. We're just telling you that's not
what they believe.
>> I'm an Orthodox Jew and I can believe
that.
>> No, bro. No. You're going against
Judaism, dude.
>> Why? You're I'm an Orthodox Jew. You're
>> I'm glad you believe this. Trust me, I'm
glad you believe this. I'm just telling
you that
>> I know, but the only difference between
you and me is that you believe that the
Messiah already have come and been unal
alived. And I don't believe that the the
Messiah has come already and been alive.
We in fact, we pray every day that the
Messiah should come and that Jerusalem
and the the the temple should be.
>> Yeah. So, so, so when the Messiah comes,
will you accept that his sacrifice is
going to be the reason why you're able
to get to heaven and be with God is
because he atoned for your sins?
>> I don't I don't see I don't see that a
By the way, I don't believe it's Jesus.
I don't believe it was Jesus and I don't
believe in the second coming.
>> Wait, wait. I have a better question.
>> Don't corner me in that one.
>> I have a better question. If the
Messiah, if you believe the Messiah is
supposed to atone for our sins, why is
it then that you believe when the
Messiah comes, the temple will be
rebuilt for sacrifices?
>> No, I didn't say for sacrifices. I said
the temple
>> that's what the temple is for. It's for
sacrifices. That's that's why they get
the red heers ready. Do you know what
has to happen before the third temple?
>> Not necessarily.
>> Okay. Wait, what are the red heers for
then on the third temple?
>> The Have you ever heard of Mymanities?
>> Yes. Mymonades. Yes, I've heard of that.
Mymanity says that the only reason that
sacrifices were ever brought 2,000 years
ago on the altar was because at that
time the other religions used um
sacrifices either human or animal and
and the Jew and even the Jews couldn't
comprehend a worship of a god that
didn't include any sacrifices.
says, "One second, one second. My says
that in when the Messiah comes and the
temple is rebuilt that we will not need
any animal sacrifice."
>> Why is it that there needs to be five I
believe it's five unstained red heers
then for the temple? Why? Why is that?
>> That was when the that was when the
temple was built last time.
>> This is the new Nope. This is the new
temple.
>> Where where do you show show me in
scripture that in the new temple? show
you that there has to be red houses for
a new temple to be built.
>> I don't think that's true. That's not
what Mymonities would would agree with.
Granted, other Orthodox rabbis would
disagree vehemently with the Mymonities,
but um but it's not necessarily true
that we'll need sacrifices in the third
temple.
>> Yeah, but that also doesn't have
anything to do with the fact that the
Messiah will die. I don't.
>> Oh, it does though because if there are
red heers, okay, then that means that
there are still sacrifices. Why would
there need to be sacrifices if the
Messiah is the atonement for your sins?
>> I don't know why because apparently the
the the sacrifices would not be enough.
>> But if the Messiah sacrifice is the
sacrifice that atones for your sins,
>> people do sins every day. There are so
many people do so many sins.
>> Yeah. But the point is the Messiah here
in Isaiah 53 is supposed to atone for
all of our sins. He's supposed to be the
final atonement.
>> Where do you read that in the scripture?
I that's not written in the scripture.
It just says that he will bear that.
Yes. When he says that we are healed by
this and that he was wounded for our
iniquities.
>> It doesn't say all iniquities inquities
>> the iniquity of
>> Yeah. And that he has the Lord has laid
on him the iniquity of us all.
>> Yeah.
Okay. So, the guilt of all of us. So, so
that's that's a very that's a misnomer
of the of the translation in English
when it says we all went it's a
misnomer. We all went astray like she
each each of us going our own way
meaning we're leaving God and God
visited upon him the guilt of all of us.
It doesn't mean all of our sins. It
means the sins of all of us. No,
>> learn Hebrew. It's the Hebrew and the
original.
>> What is guilt?
>> The guilt of all of us, the sin of all
of us.
>> So, explain to me then what is a guilt
offering in the Old Testament?
>> A guilt offering, a guilt offering is
when you don't know um let's say for
example, uh I don't know, Jews are not
supposed to eat pork. Let's say for
example, and let's say I have two
packages of meat. Both of them I wake I
wake up in the morning. I I realize I
ate one from one of the packages of meat
and I don't know which one was pork and
which one was kosher. So you as that
type of person has to bring in a certain
type of offering called a guilt
offering.
>> Yeah. Because of the fact that you might
have sinned. Correct.
>> You might have sinned. Yes.
>> Exactly. So a guilt offering is still
going to be about your sin.
>> Even if it's potential sin, it's still
about your sin.
>> It's about Yeah. But not all. It doesn't
have to be all your sins. I think we're
just
>> I didn't say about sin. I didn't say
>> Yeah. Yeah. I didn't say that that the
guilt offering was for all your sins.
I'm saying this is for all your sins.
And we know that iniquity here is
talking about sins because of the fact
that a guilt offering in the Old
Testament was for sins.
>> Okay? That doesn't mean that it doesn't
mean that a Messiah can't come along and
and and and bear some of the other
iniquities of of
>> the Messiah is going to put an end to
sin.
>> Yeah.
>> And bringing everlasting righteousness.
That's what Daniel 9 says.
>> Okay. I believe that, too.
>> Okay.
>> I believe in you're I believe in the
Hebrew Bible. That's what I believe in.
>> Good. So if you believe the Hebrew
Bible, then you believe that the Messiah
is going to and when he comes, he atones
for your sins, puts it puts an end to
sin and transgression and atones for the
iniquity, brings everlasting
righteousness, and he's the last of the
revelations. So with that being said,
Isaiah 53 pointing to the to the Messiah
along coupled with Daniel 9 that tells
us that he brings an end to he finishes
it, but also that after that after his
him being cut off from the land of the
living, the sanctuary, the temple of
Jerusalem gets destroyed and that
happened in 70 AD, brother.
>> Yeah. And then by the way too in Isaiah
53 when it literally talks about and as
a root out of dry ground. How does a
root grow of dry ground?
>> I think I think it means that the
certain natural um rules are going to be
uh subverted.
>> That's what it really means. It also
says that the that the sheep will lay
with the lion. Meaning,
>> no, that's talking about in the end
times,
>> right? So,
>> so this isn't talking about the end
times. This is talking about whoever is
being spoken about Isaiah 53 that out of
root out of dry ground he will grow. How
does a root grow out of dry ground?
Because a root a root.
>> So how do you interpret that?
>> So this is actually going to be
referring to the virgin birth of the
Messiah because a root cannot grow out
of dry ground like you cannot be born
from a woman without a seed.
>> What verse is that?
>> Isaiah 53:2. So just like in the fact
that a woman cannot bear a child without
seed, a root cannot grow without water.
This is referring to the virgin birth.
>> I don't know how you jump from that to
the virgin birth.
>> Yeah. Because Okay. How does a root
>> I know it's allegorical, but the
>> how does a root That's why I asked how
does a root grow out of dry ground?
>> How does a root grow out of dry ground?
It it obviously can't obviously
>> referring to something that is springing
out of another that cannot occur
naturally. What is this referring to?
>> I think it's
I agree with you that it's a metaphor,
but it doesn't have to mean that.
>> Yeah, we're saying it's the only way it
makes sense is if it's referring to a
virgin birth. So, so I'll tell you. I
don't know if Have you heard of Rashi?
>> Yes, I know Rashi.
>> Okay. So, he he's he said he doesn't say
that it's Jesus or or the virgin birth.
He says,
>> "Who cares?"
>> So, who is it then? So, what does it
mean then? What does Rash say?
>> I I'll tell you what he says. And he
came up like a sapling before it. This
people before this greatness came to it
was a very humble people and it came up
by itself like a sapling of the saplings
of the trees.
>> That has nothing to do with growing out
of dry ground. How what does it mean to
grow out of ground
>> and like a like a root he came up from.
He doesn't comment on that.
>> Exactly.
>> Who doesn't? That's the point.
>> I'll tell you I'll tell you what Ibanzra
says. And as a root out of dry ground
that neither produces fruit nor
distinguishes itself by its size. So if
you have a root coming out of dry land,
meaning it's not that tree can grow out,
but it's not going to produce any fruit
and it doesn't distinguish itself by
>> No, a root's not going to grow without
water, dude. The land might be dry.
>> It's not going to grow out. The tree is
not gonna grow without water. Trees
don't grow without water.
>> Okay, I I can grant you that, but I
don't know how you're jumping from
Ezra saying it's wrong. That's not
referring to that. It can't because a
tree doesn't grow without water.
>> Okay. I mean, you're assuming Okay. So,
you're saying that it's a Messiah. I can
Okay, let's say it is the Messiah.
>> Okay, great. So, the Messiah will So,
let's get this straight.
>> But your Messiah is not my Messiah.
>> Okay, but let's get this straight. The
Messiah will be born from a virgin. He
will come and he will be crucified.
>> That I didn't say was going to be born
of a virgin. I didn't say that.
>> Okay. So, so then tell me what out of
Adam out of drag means. I
>> I can give you a million. I can give you
a million.
>> Give me a single one yet.
>> Is that the only meaning that you can
come up with come up with?
>> Give me a single meaning.
>> All right. Let me find what Malbum says.
>> You can't. You don't have any. That's
the point. So, aroo out of dry ground.
We have the Messiah here coming from a
virgin. We have the Messiah here dying
for the sins of all. Guess what? That's
Christianity.
>> It probably means that he's going to It
probably means that he's going to be
born in a place that doesn't have a lot
of opportunity, but he's going to create
opportunity and and make and grow and
build himself up and be a self-made man.
That's what's
really quick. I just want to give a
shout. What's up, Radar Apologetics?
Welcome to the panel, man.
>> What is up, brother? God bless. God
bless. How's everybody doing? What's up,
man?
>> Man, doing pretty good, man. Doing
pretty good. Uh, got a rabbitic Jew on
the stage that we're having a good
conversation with.
>> Oh, nice, man. Nice.
>> Sammy, right? What's up, Sammy? How are
you?
>> Yes, sir. What's going on?
>> Good, man. What's going on? You think
Jesus is the Messiah, right?
>> No.
>> Why not?
>> Why not? Why do you Why not? Well, you
know, you know what? I'll answer first.
>> Ask you first, bro.
>> He didn't He didn't He didn't bring
world peace. He didn't um end iniquity
because everyone is still sitting. Um,
>> let's deal with that. Give me Yeah.
Okay. Well, let's deal with that. Let's
deal with one of the puk in the Torah
that tells come
>> Oh, snap.
>> He's lagging really bad.
>> You're cutting out a little bit.
>> Message in the Torah that when Messiah
comes, he It's okay. It's okay, brother.
I just came I'm coming back from New
York City where we're planting a
Messianic synagogue in the upper east
side. So, service is a little bit wonky,
bro. Give me a passage in the Torah, in
the prophets, anywhere that say that
when the Messiah comes, he'll
immediately bring peace.
>> There are many.
>> Are you there?
>> Give me one. Give me one immediately.
Okay. It says in that time in that time
that will come that the that the sheep
will lay with the lion. What does that
mean that the sheep will lay with the
lion? It means that there will be one.
>> Show me. Do you have the word friend? Do
you have the word immediately in there?
Is that what happened? Yes, you have the
sheep with a language that does exist.
>> Sure. Sure. Who is the Messiah son of?
Who's the Messiah son of?
>> The Messiah is going to be the son of
David.
>> Sure. Let me ask you a question. When
David became king,
>> let me ask you a question. When Sure.
When David became king, did he
immediately instant rule over the
kingdom?
>> King David? Not immediately. No. He was
appointed by God.
>> No, of course not.
>> Okay. Okay. So, when when did King David
become king? Am I thinking like what was
it like? It was like a I don't remember
like 200 BC something like that.
>> Okay. Well, well, let's think about like
this. How old was how old was Sam Kog
David when he became king? When he got
anointed as king was something like 17.
Was he 17?
>> Sure. Sure. So if you walked around the
land of Israel, if you walked around
Eris Israel in the time right after
Samuel anointed King David, and you
walked around and you told people who's
the king, what are people going to say
>> after he became king or before he became
king?
>> After he got anointed as a boy by Samuel
in the house of his father Jesse, when
he got anointed and you go outside and
you ask people who's the king of Israel,
who are they going to say?
>> David.
>> They're going to say David. You're going
to go up to somebody and they're going
to say David is king.
>> Why not? Yeah. right after he got
anointed as a boy.
>> Right. Not the second after.
>> Okay. So there you go. So now you can be
anointed king over Israel and yet the
people don't recognize it and you don't
see the ramifications of his rule
immediately. You would say that's true,
right?
>> Fine. Okay.
>> Okay. So we have a model inside the
prophets. Check me out in a week or two.
Prophets. Check me out. Sammy. Sammy.
Listen, man. We have a model inside of
the Hebrew Bible.
>> Listen, David became king. Okay? And
nobody thought he was king. Actually, he
went back in the field with the rest of
the animals until Saul called him.
>> The same thing. So too, we have a model
that when Messiah comes, Messiah, who's
a son of David, what happens to him? He
also goes through stages of redemption,
stages for the gula, my friend.
>> Okay, I agree with that. That's
something I agree with.
>> Okay, so this is why this is why Messiah
could come and we don't see world peace.
Just like when David got anointed as
king, no, the world, the rest of Israel
didn't see David as king, although he
was the rightful king. Because if you
ask God who's king the day after Samuel
anointed him, they would say David's
king. But Saul is reigning upon the
throne for now. So too with the Messiah,
he's the king of Israel, but we have the
king of this world who's ruling right
now. But the day will come, my friend,
check it out. The day will come when
Mashiach will come back and all of
Israel will accept him. You want to hear
the most fascinating part about all of
this is that when the next time when's
the next time David got anointed?
>> I don't know. You tell me.
>> In Hebron. In Hebron. In Hebron.
>> And who who crowned him as king? Only
Judah. One tribe. She Yehuda.
It wasn't until seven years later that
all of Israel accepted him. Brother, we
are in the time where the remnant of the
house of Israel, the first ones are
beginning to receive the Messiah back,
brother. And the whole house of the
early remnant is receiving him and
accepting him as Messiah. And the day
will come where all of Israel will
profess him as the Messiah. When they
will see him, when they will mourn for
him as one mourns for a son.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen.
>> Okay. So, do you have to worship him,
though? As a part of
>> No, no. Don't go anywhere else. Don't go
anywhere else for a second. You So, you
we'll get We'll get to the worship,
brother. Don't worry. It's it's it's
your time, okay? I'm just visiting,
okay? We'll get there. Don't worry.
Okay.
>> This is your time. This is your time.
Listen, this is your time. Listen. So,
so listen. So, you can agree that there
can be stages of the redemption the same
way there were stages for David.
>> Of course.
>> Okay. So, he can be Messiah. he can be
king and we just don't see it yet. Now,
let's talk about him actually.
>> They didn't listen, they didn't have
Twitter, okay? So, not everyone's going
to know, right?
>> Nobody has Twitter. It's called XY.
>> Nobody had X 3,000 years, 2,000 years
ago, but within a week or two, everyone
knew that he was king, obviously.
>> No, brother. Nobody thought he was king,
brother. He was still ruling. He was So,
you're trying to tell me he was king of
Israel. Everybody knew he was king, and
they still kicked him out and sent him
amongst the Philistines. Well, because
he's Saul still had followers.
>> Okay. So, no, brother. The people didn't
recognize him as king. That's why even
when they crowned him as king by Judah,
the the rest of Israel didn't accept
him. Friend, you already agreed that
their state of redemption. It's all
good. It's not a problem.
>> Okay.
>> Judaism teaches this. They even say that
that you have you ever heard the phrase?
Have you ever heard the phrase that as
it was with the first redeemer, so it
will be with the last redeemer? Well, we
only believe in one redeemer, but we
don't
>> Did you ever hear that?
>> No, I didn't.
>> So, so this is what I'm saying, brother.
We have we have models of stages of
redemption. Now, let's get to the
Messiah being God and being worshiped.
Do you know that in Midash Tuma? Are you
familiar with that?
>> Of course. I mean, this is our bread and
butter.
>> Of course. Do do you know in midrash it
says that the Messiah is greater than
Abraham, Isaac, Jacob, Moses, and even
>> I'll get into a bad space.
>> Yeah. I Yeah. Can I can I just can I
just cut in for a second? I I get what
you're I get the chain of events and
ideas that you're you're presenting to
me, but I want to I want to kind of
answer your original question.
>> The Jewish ideas, right?
>> No, these are scriptural ideas. I'm not
talking about anything Jewish. Okay,
good.
So, we did So, what did we do? Okay, so
the Messiah,
>> but just recap real quick. The Messiah
can have stages to redemption. That's
not a problem. And we just established
that the Messiah is even greater than
the angels. Just to begin, but what
where do you want to go now?
>> No, I'm I'm I'm not I'm not arguing with
that. I'm just saying if you look in
Isaiah 11, it does talk about that fact
that the Messiah has to bring world
peace. Um, that is a a very big it's
going to it's going to bring a great
piece. The Talmet also says it.
>> I'm sorry. Did you just time travel to
15 minutes ago, brother? Brother, did
you just time travel the 15 minutes ago,
brother? We just addressed
Messiah stages to redemption. No,
brother. Stages to redemption. The
Messiah have stages to redemption. If
David can be anointed as king and people
don't recognize him as king, so too,
Messiah can be anointed as king. and the
world doesn't recognize him yet.
>> I don't know. I don't know about that
jump. I don't know about that jump. A
king is not the same. A king is a
political figure.
>> Uh the Messiah is a spiritual figure. So
that's where I that's where I don't
necessarily can agree with that.
>> We do call the Messiah to be the king.
>> But but at the time he will be the king.
But
>> you know, but but it doesn't mean that
David himself was the Messiah per se as
is described in scripture. I'm sure you
agree with that too. I'm not really sure
where you're trying to get with that,
but let let I I don't know where you
want to go with this. I'm really trying
to get you to deal with the fact about
King David having stages to redemption.
I also brought up and this is something
else just an evidence from the sages of
Israel. Um they also say how the first
redeemer is like the last redeemer and
that the first redemption will be like
the last redemption. And so Moses came
and was rejected by the people, went
away and then was accepted later. So too
with the Messiah, this is how it's going
to be. So if Moses was rejected and then
accepted, and the Messiah is going to
have the same type of redemption
according to Judaism. How can the
Messiah come and bring peace if the
Jewish people have to reject him?
>> I I understand your allegory. Um I could
>> now my this is the sages of Israel.
>> The sages of Israel.
They said you're saying that they said
that Moshe Moses was rejected.
>> The first redeemer will be like the lost
redeemer. the first then accepted that
it so to the Messiah will be rejected
then accepted.
>> Okay. Well, who's But why does that
prove that Jesus was the one? Why does
it prove that? That Jesus will
>> Because you're saying the Messiah is
going to come and be accepted and
there's going to be immediate peace. I'm
saying just like Moses, the Messiah was
rejected by the Jewish people and then
he'll be accepted by them just like
Moses.
>> Well, if he's the one that comes in, you
know, in the future, I'm, you know, I
don't have to reject that. But I don't
have to believe that he already I
>> You don't have to believe
>> I don't have to believe that he already
>> Okay, let's go down there. Let's go down
that path real quick. Okay.
>> I mean, I just don't know what's forcing
you to believe that it's him.
>> Let's walk down. Well, we can deal with
that. But you said you don't have to
believe it's him. Could Abraham build an
ark? And would that be pleasing to the
Lord?
>> Sure.
>> Well, could Abraham say, "I don't want
to sacrifice my son instead of build an
ark." Well, if God tells him, "Sacrifice
your son," then no.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Could Moses say,
"Instead of me uh going up and getting
the 10 words, the ten commandments, I'm
going to sacrifice my son Gersham."
>> No.
>> Okay. Could King David said, "Nope, I'm
not going to do the plans for the
temple. Instead, I'm going to go up and
get the 10 words."
>> No.
>> From Mount Si. Okay. Why? Because they
had to operate in what God was telling
them to do at that time period. If you
go to Daniel 9:24-27,
even according to Rashi, the end of that
time is the first century.
>> According to Rashi, the end of that time
was the first century.
>> Yeah.
>> And so the Rashi said that the Messiah
had come before the
>> No, Rashi says that the time period of
the 480 years takes you to the first
century.
>> What 480 years?
>> The 480 years, brother. the 480 uh 49
>> 83 years that lead up
>> after the building of Jerusalem
>> in Daniel 9.
>> No, brother. After the building of Jer
Jerusalem, after the rebuilding of
Jerusalem, the city, there's 483 years
before Messiah will be cut off.
>> Most most Jewish scholars wouldn't agree
with that interpretation.
>> Of course not. Because they don't want
to believe that Yeshua is the Messiah.
>> Why wouldn't we want to believe that the
Messiah came? Like why do you think that
we don't want
>> brother? because there are things deeply
embedded within rebbitic Judaism that
are diametrically opposed to the Hebrew
Bible.
>> Okay, it's a little dicey territory, but
I'm going to ask you what you think the
our motivation is that we wouldn't why
wouldn't rabbis want to believe that
Mashiah came?
>> Because it shatters their perspective of
what the uh Tanakh is clearly teaching.
Even Isaiah 53, we were just talking
about, we were just talking about King
David, right? He gets rejected. He gets
sent off. He goes on the run, right? He
suffers for them. This is a model of
what the servant does. We even we have
the high priest. The first time Messiah
appears, the word Messiah appears.
Leviticus 4:3. This is a priest that
carries the names of the sons of Israel
into the holy place. This is the model
of the ultimate Messiah. But you would
say, "No, this isn't the model of the
ultimate Messiah."
>> Okay.
>> So, the question for you is, why do you
hold positions that that disregard the
Hebrew Bible? It's not for me. I don't
know why Judaism would do it.
>> Well, because they would they would
interpret the the Hebrew Bible as not
believing in that. Like for example, if
you look at Isaiah 2 um verses 2 through
4, it says a shoot will shall grow out
of the stump of Jesse. The spirit of God
will come to him.
>> Yeah.
>> And then for sure that's great,
>> right?
>> Amen. You better preach that word, bro.
>> I agree with that. And we just interpret
it in different ways. But if you look at
verse six, it says, "The wolf shall
dwell with the lamb. The leopard shall
lie down with the goat." Meaning,
>> sure,
>> implying that there's going to be world
peace, and we do not
>> Is the word immediate? Is the word
immediately there?
>> Well, I mean, it's definitely got to
happen within 2,000 years, don't you
think?
>> So, let me ask you a question. Did
Isaiah understand the time of David?
>> Did Isaiah understand?
>> Did he know? Yeah. Did Isaiah understand
David? Did he understand? Of course, he
did. Of course. So therefore, when he's
writing things, he expects you to know
the Torah and the prophets as well and
to know the model of the stages of
redemption. So that when you're looking
at these things, you wouldn't expect it
to immediately happen. The word
immediately is not there in the passage,
my friend.
>> Well, it's it's not going to be 2,000
years late. I mean, 202.
>> You have a verse that says it won't be
2,000 years.
>> I mean, it's within reason. It's not
going to be it's not going to be like
that. I I
>> Do you have a verse? Is this what Moses
believed? Did Moshe tell you this? Give
me a verse, brother, that tells me that
it can't be in 2,000 years.
>> Okay. Outside of the New Testament, can
you tell me in the Hebrew Bible where it
says a verse that it says Jesus Christ?
>> Sure. Tell Show it to me. Show me the
verse that says it's going to be
>> You broke up with you broke up. You
broke up. I didn't hear. Say it again.
>> I didn't hear it. Say it again. Can you
show me in a a verse in the Hebrew Bible
that says the Messiah is going to be
Jesus Christ who has not brought the end
to sin, who has not brought world peace,
who has not redeemed the Jews and built
a new temple, who has not done all these
things that we believe we need and to
have a post a post suffering era.
Suffering still exists.
>> It tells us what the Messiah is going to
do and what the servant's going to do.
tells us exactly what it's going to do
and where it's open-ended. It allows for
that room of interpretation. Let's walk
your line of logic. The micdash is
built. Let's all right, the temple's
rebuilt. Then what?
>> What do you mean then? What? That's he
didn't do that.
>> Mashia comes, the temple rebuilt. What
happens?
>> There's world peace. People know that
Hashem is God and that there's only one
God and and there's no other. We don't
worship any idols or things like that.
We commit sin.
>> Can can people sin? Can people still
sin?
>> Okay. So, you're getting to the
nitty-gritty.
>> I'm asking you. This is your worldview.
Can people still sin?
>> Of course, people can still sin. But,
but people are going
>> Okay. So, will
people not want
>> What's that?
>> His connection. Let his connection come
back.
>> Yeah. I'll wait.
>> Are you there?
>> There we go.
>> I'm here. I'd love to hear what you have
to say. Radar, do you have a real name?
Oh,
>> yeah. In any case,
>> hold on. Radar, can you hear us? name.
>> My name is My name's Avery.
>> Avery. Good to meet you, too. Uh, too.
I'm shame to hear that he's he built a
uh a temple.
>> You're from New York.
>> I'm from Brooklyn, baby.
>> How How Well, how far are you from Time
Square?
>> Like an hour train ride.
>> Oh, well, we're we're going to be out
I'm going to be visiting um in August.
So, next month on the 15th through the
18th, I'll be um in Time Square and
we'll be like inviting people for
conversations like just like this. So,
>> Oh, that's that's cool. You're going to
make a YouTube video and stuff.
>> Mhm.
>> That's cool. That's cool. You're going
to be preaching the gospel?
>> Preaching the gospel of the Messiah,
man. Of the Messiah.
>> All right, baby.
>> All right, bro. We're back. Heard of
>> Oh, you're back. Okay.
>> Sorry. Thank you, Avery. My bad.
>> Yeah.
saying, "What stops another exile from
falling to Jewish?"
>> Wait, what stops what radar? He cut out
again.
>> World peace party.
>> Hold on. Hold on. He cut out again. I
>> What stops another exile?
>> Ah,
>> what stops another
>> What stops another exile?
>> Okay,
>> I'll I'll tell you. I'll tell you that.
That's part and parcel of of what I've
been saying that he's going to bring
world peace. The fact
>> we were exiled from I love your assures,
by the way. They're very they're very
serious and authentic. Sure. Um uh but
uh sure the every exile has been because
of the the Romans, there were the
Greeks, there were um many and many
reasons we were kicked out of the land
of Israel and Sure.
>> and and Messiah when the Messiah brings
world peace then we will need to be
kicked out. You understand?
>> Sure. So let me ask you a question
though s you said that it's because of
the Romans. Doesn't the Torah say that
if Israel was obedient to the Torah that
no enemy would be able to overtake them?
>> Right. We were not obedient,
unfortunately.
>> So, it's not the Romans, it's the Greeks
is because Israel doesn't know how to
behave.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So, now if there's still sin
within Israel, if they still have the
potential for sin, what stops another
exile from happening and them getting
kicked out? Messiah's here. There's
peace, but what stops us from sinning?
>> Right? So I so I I don't know if you got
cut out before but the idea is that the
the Messiah is going to bring such a
spiritual
transformation to the world that no one
will see any point in sinning.
>> Okay. Okay. So now let's
>> Okay. Now let's work it out. All right.
So you know that's not consistent but
let's go somewhere else with it. Okay.
Let's look at the other side. Okay.
Messiah comes
>> and and the land will be filled with the
knowledge of God.
>> Okay. Land is filled with the knowledge
of God. Let's walk through your world.
All right.
They don't
show them they got lambs and wool and
all this good stuff happening. All
right. Now, the world is restored,
right? You there? The world's restored
now.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> Are you there?
>> Yes. Sure.
>> All right. So, the world's restored.
Everything's peaceful. Okay. Everybody
knows God. You have a world, you have a
system, brother, where you have God and
you also have this man, human king that
rules over the people when everybody's
restored back into a right relationship
with God.
>> Sure.
>> How is that possible? How is that
possible?
>> How is it possible to have a king when
we're worship?
>> You have a man rules over the people and
everybody into a private relationship to
God. Isn't the Lord supposed to be the
one and the only one? And isn't he the
king over the whole world?
>> You're speaking Samuel's gospel. If you
look at Samuel
um where the Jews said, "We want to have
a king like all the other nations."
Samuel gets very very
God intervening.
>> No, no, no. I'll explain why it is.
Because he says that when they asked for
a king, they rejected me as king. So,
how can Israel have a human king and and
Hashem be the king? As it says in at the
end of Zechariah, his name will be one,
the only one. Just like when we do Odon
and we do those liturgy and the prayer,
we sing about God's kingship. How can
Hashem be king, but now we have a man
king? How was it possible before?
>> I know Hebrew so well. I I'm starting to
think that you're Jewish.
>> Yeah. You know, some people think that.
Let me I think back up if you look at
look at Samuel it said God God speaks to
Samuel and says you want a king because
they hating me.
>> God
>> no they said they rejected me as king
brother they rejected me
>> or or or whatever I I don't know the
word word by word for word but I know
that God says that they will reject
reject
>> they rejected me. So, how can you have
if everybody knows Hashem, how can you
have a world system where everybody
knows Hashem and they have a man king
that was born like 30 years ago and now
he rules, he brings peace, but now we
have another king and Hashem's king. How
can it not be a rejection of God as king
when you have another king now?
>> We had many kings that while we were
>> and it was always a rejection of God as
king, my friend.
>> No, I mean when Solomon was king, we
didn't reject God. When Solomon came,
everything was flourishing in the land
of
>> No, Hashem had already been rejected.
Solomon brings a ton, brother. He brings
a partial restoration
Hashem to dwell in the Beta Mikdash,
>> right? He built the temple.
>> Okay? So, he's doing a ton. He's
bringing a restoration. But when the
restoration is complete, use have a dude
on the throne. Zechariah tells us his
name will be one and the only one.
>> Yeah. But I I don't know why I have to
believe that it's Jesus. I don't why do
I have to believe that it's Jesus? Why
can't
>> brother? Because what I'm saying to you,
it's not just about believing it's
Jesus. I want you, my friend. Listen,
seriously, brother and Allah, you know,
really
>> consider your world.
>> I don't have to agree with
>> No, brother. This is this No, it's not
about agreeing. No, I want you to
consider this. that you have a worldview
that when everything's done and from
your perspective what's going to work
out, you got another if you were Muslim.
>> Not I'm not completely sure what you
said, but I I I I get what you're
saying. I get
if you if you are Muslim, if if you are
Muslim, this would be considered sh
>> true. Even if you're Jew No. Oh, you
mean if you believe that the in the
Messiah this
Listen, what you're doing is [__]
You're attributing partners to Hashem.
>> What? That I believe that God reveals
himself in man form.
>> No. Shitu is that you have a partner
with Hashem. You have somebody else on
Hashem's throne in the restored order.
In the restored order.
>> Okay. So, I'll tell you what the
rabbitical understanding of the word
means. It means that I believe in God.
>> Sure. Okay. I believe in God himself,
the ineffable, omnipresent,
all knowing God, but I also believe in
um I don't know in John Smith as being
God as well. And I believe in a um um
okay Sandy Sandy uh Sandy whatever as
being God as part of God. That's sh
which is forbidden. Um and which
actually is not philosophically
sound because God does not change. God
is absolute and he will never change. He
will never change his mind. He will
never say, "Oh, wait a second. I need to
make an amendment to my Hebrew Bible.
Oh, you know what? I need to add a new
chapter. I forgot about that." God is
all knowing. He's in there's no time up
there in space. There's no future past
is time is a fourth dimension over here
on earth. Up there there are no all
kinds in all places. So it wouldn't make
sense. It's just not philosophically
sound. I don't have to believe that it's
idolatry. It is. But it's just not
philosophically sound. If it was, I
wouldn't have any issue believing it.
But
>> well, Sammy Well, Sammy, what I'm saying
is I just want to say this last point.
You know, my whole point is that you're
not you may not be saying that this man
is God, but you put him in a place that
only Hashem belongs. That's my point.
>> So, so according to you then why
shouldn't every king have a problem with
with with sharing the throne with God
order?
>> This was because there's there's because
there's friend there's there's sin in
the world and sin has to be dealt with.
When sin is dealt with Zachchariah tells
us that his name will be one and the
only one that he will be king over the
whole earth over the whole earth. Now he
can't be king over the whole earth
because now you got another man who's a
king with him.
>> Don't you believe that Jesus is king?
>> I believe Jesus is king but he's also
Hashem.
>> Oh. So that's
>> just like I told you in the midash. Just
like I told you in the midash. He's
greater than the ministering angels. Are
you familiar with the midash that says
that the spirit of God that was over the
waters
is actually the spirit of God of the
Messiah.
>> Okay. So let me answer you in an al let
me answer you like this. You have you
have the mayor of New York, right? And
then you also have you also have a
representative of the New York state and
then you have the federal and then you
have international or the or or the UN
or whatever and then you have God. So in
the land of Israel, I could have the
representative or the governor of each
state and then have, you know, the
representative of the entire country and
then I can have the representative of
the entire of of the entire world, which
is God. I don't have to believe that
he's sharing the throne with God. I I
just
>> What's that? I missed you.
>> So in a restored order, how many kings
do you have when everything's restored?
How many kings do you have?
>> You have It depends what you mean by
king. If you mean by politically, I mean
I would say the Messiah is the king. If
you mean the the king that I worship and
bow down to, then I would say God.
>> I think it's a very easy question to
answer.
>> All right. Well, look, Sammy, look,
Sammy. I'm moving back to the city. I
grew up in Brooklyn. I've been in
Pennsylvania for a little bit. I'm
putting a congregation in uh I'm putting
a Messianic synagogue inside the Upper
East Side.
>> How much is that going to cost you?
>> All right. So, maybe we can
>> maybe we can connect. You know what I
mean? I don't have a problem with
connecting, but
>> you know, maybe we could connect,
brother. I'll meet up with you in the
city. It's not a problem there every
day.
>> What's that?
>> Upper East Side is
>> Upper East Side is a very It's a very
Jewish area. Look, you sound like you're
Jewish, bro. It's crazy.
>> I see.
>> Beautiful. Sammy, blesses. All right.
Thank you so much for the conversation,
bro. I appreciate so much. Avery, thanks
for having me up, brother. I appreciate
>> it. Only great things.
>> Blessings to you, too, brother. Sammy,
connect with me in the in the back
thing, brother. Send me an email, a
text. All right. No problemmo.
>> All right, brother. The blessings, man.
Avery, thanks for having me, bro.
Blessings, everybody. Thank you.
>> God bless. God bless. Yeah. See, Sam,
I'm gonna bring up some other guests
now, but man, thank you for the
conversation. Really was fun to listen,
man.
>> Yeah,
>> you're doing great work. I love
discussing this stuff. I love hearing
your your stuff. I'm going to hit you a
follow right now. All right.
>> For sure. For sure. Hope to see you
again, man.
>> Peace and love.
>> All right. Peace.
>> Bye.
>> Hey, I just want to say I love you, bro.
Thanks for Thanks for inviting me up,
brother. I appreciate that. I love you
too, man. You know, you know, I had to
bring the master up for this one, man.
You know, so
ain't a thing if I don't if I don't call
call the master and come come do this
real quick.
>> I know, brother. Glory to the Messiah,
man. Listen, you know, Sammy's a really
cool dude, brother. And I'm sure I'll
see him come through with services. You
know, we're getting ready Friday night,
brother. Friday night, first service.
>> For sure. Hey, you see that? We got We
got 2600 people watching on YouTube,
man. Tell us what you're up to.
>> That's awesome, man. Yes. planting a
messianic synagogue on the upper east
side is that's the website. Please do go
check it out if you want to support.
We're trying to raise some funds for it.
Go through check it out. We'll be live
streaming. The handles are upper
room_nyc
upper room upper room_nyc.
Amy, thank you so much, brother. I
appreciate you.
>> Love you, too, man. Thanks for coming.
>> All right, man. Love you, brother. Talk
to you later, man. Nick, good seeing
you, bro.
>> God bless, bro.
>> All right, guys. Guys, that was Radar
Apologetics
uh bringing us to class, man. Taking us
to school. Love listening to him, man.
Love listening to him methodically cook
rabbitic Judaism and just walk it. I
love his style. The way he walks through
it, it's just I love it. Okay. Um we got
somebody named Servant of God. Nick, you
you you uh you still there? You you
still with me?
>> I'm with you, bro. I'm here.
>> All right. All right. We got somebody.
He's on uh he's on YouTube.
>> YouTube live. Yeah.
>> Servant of God, about to bring you up,
man.
>> Hey, man. Can you hear me?
>> All right. You there, servant of God,
can you hear us?
>> Yep. I'm here. Can you hear me?
>> No, no, no, no. Okay.
>> So, I believe that Islam is a true
because it doesn't contradiction to
itself.
>> It doesn't contradict itself.
>> Yeah. Because Muslim doesn't believe
Muslim doesn't wait. Muslim doesn't say
that uh Allah is not a god. And the
other chapters say is Allah is a god.
>> Okay. But you have uh verses that say
Allah is all powerful and then verses
demonstrating that he's not all
powerful.
>> Where?
>> Like for example, do you believe that
Allah can have a son if he wanted?
>> What do you mean by that?
>> Could he have a son if he wanted to?
>> No. When when he say that it's just like
a Quranic speakers, it's mean. How I can
explain you? Uh
>> could he have a son if he wanted?
>> No, it's contradiction to his uh nature,
the God's nature.
>> All right. So when Allah says that he
could have a son if he wanted to, does
he saying is he saying he could
contradict his nature? Yes.
>> So Allah can contradict his nature.
>> No, I mean wait don't change my words.
Don't change my words. I
>> I didn't. I just I just repeated.
>> Yeah.
>> If God have son, so it's contradiction
to his natures. Do you agree with that?
>> No.
>> Why?
>> You you're you're saying that?
>> No. Do you agree with me?
>> I don't agree with you. And so when we
could talk about that in a second,
>> but if you're saying that Allah having a
son is a contradiction to his nature,
>> well, so when Allah says that he can
have a son if he wanted to, that means
that Allah is saying that he can
contradict his nature. Right.
>> Where he doesn't change the word.
>> Okay, you're right. You're right. I I
probably misqu
>> I know about what are you saying?
>> Okay, I'm I'm sorry. I'm okay. You're
right. I'm misquing.
>> But my question is that for you,
>> but but if you relax, you still didn't
answer the question. If God said, if
Allah said that he could have a son if
he wanted to, would that be Allah
acknowledging that he can contradict his
nature?
>> Where he say that?
>> I didn't say he did. I'm saying if he
said that.
>> I hypothetical.
>> Don't say that, bro. If he if he doesn't
say that,
>> bro.
>> Han, if you if you can't engage, man,
I'm going to have to move on.
>> Okay. I'm I'm going to say I'm going to
tell you. So, is God say,
>> so are you going to are you going to
answer the question? If God said if all
I said,
>> it's going to be contradiction. It's
going to be contradict to his nature.
Yes, of course.
>> Okay. All right. Got you. So, uh, if you
go to 39:4, Allah says he can have a son
if you want it.
>> He don't say that. Which verse? Which
verse? Which verse? Which verse?
>> Chapter 39.
>> Verse four.
>> Which verse?
>> Four.
>> Welcome everybody. Welcome everybody.
We're just getting warmed up.
>> Chapter 38, verse 4.
>> Chapter 39, verse number four. That's
why I usually don't say the verse until
you guys go to the chapter cuz I will
have to repeat it like 10 times.
>> But that's normal. like normal human
beings in general. Anyway, yep, guys, as
you guys are going in, we got Fearless
Truth with us. His title is in I mean
his uh YouTube is in the title of this
video. So, go ahead and go to the title
of this video, click his YouTube name,
it'll take you straight to his channel
and give my brother a subscription. Make
sure you like his videos, comment on
them, help the algorithm over there.
Let's support our brother, man, as he's
doing work for the kingdom of God, cuz
he's just so awesome. Oh, love you,
Glaze. All right, while we wait, uh,
just an example of of why we wait in the
song that we play.
>> That's me. That's me.
>> That's what
>> that's meer.
>> I didn't I didn't understand what you
said.
>> Mafer meer. How can you wait?
>> Sorry, man. I didn't understand that.
I'm going to read a super chat in this
in in in the place though. So, Charles
says, "Hey,
big gifts."
>> Appreciate that, Romelo. Dang.
>> The freak. That's made for That's made
for
>> all right. One one second, Hannon. So
Charles says, "Urban, California, Orange
County, but when metaphysics Mike says
something can't be a and not a at the
same time." So how can Jesus be fully
God and fully man at the same time? You
want to go ahead and answer that?
>> Yeah. So when we say that Jesus is both
a God and man, and by the way, there's
there's an echo like I'm hearing. Is
that just going to be like because
>> it might be Hanafi? Hold on. Let me mute
Hanfi. Let's see. All right. Go ahead.
>> Testing. I still hear
>> Do you have
>> Do you have YouTube like or or
Streamyard going on?
>> I have streamer to open but I need
saying hit. Let me
>> You got your headphones in though. You
don't
>> Oh, yeah. I guess so. I can Okay, that
makes sense. All right, that makes
sense. So, I can just Okay. Yeah, that
makes sense. I'll just turn my phone up
on here.
>> All right. Uh Okay. Yeah. So, um when
metaphysics says a and not a at the same
time, how can Jesus be fully God, fully
man? Because uh when we say a and n at
the same time, that also includes in the
same sense, right? So when we're saying
that uh something cannot be a and not a
it has to also be in the same sense. Now
Jesus being fully God and fully man is
not in the same sense. It's in two
different senses. One is in the human
nature and one is in the divine nature.
Therefore, it does not follow that. It
breaks the law of non-contradiction.
>> Amen. All right. So I was saying that
the headphones should stop the echo if
you had it in.
>> No. Yeah. I took him. I was uh I still
have my headphones in on YouTube, so I
kind of hearing everything we're saying
there. It's fine now, though. We're
straight.
>> Okay. All right. Hip, you see the verse?
>> Yes, that's me.
>> It's what?
>> Metaphor.
>> Oh, metaphor.
>> No, it's not a metaphor.
>> Check. You can just check what's
it's not a metaphor at all. He says that
if if Allah wanted to have a son, he
could have one from any of his creation.
>> Okay. I I can show you example of that.
I can show you example. opens the
chapter uh chapter 20 verse 15.
>> How does that answer this?
>> I'm just shower. I'm going to show you
that
>> a metaphor.
>> Yeah. Metaphor.
>> Yeah. Can you show that it's a metaphor
in its context, bro?
>> In context?
>> Yes. You have to have the context that
shows that it's metaphorical cuz it's
not metaphor.
>> So nothing in the in the in the verse or
the context of the suggest
of even what about the verse? The verse
says, "If Allah wanted to have a son,"
Oh, excuse me. "If Allah wanted to have
a son, he could." That's what the verse
says, right?
>> No, you don't say.
>> The verse doesn't say, "Okay, hold on.
Let's Let's just go ahead and let's read
the verse.
>> Let's read the verse together.
>> Chapter 39, verse 4." Because it sounds
like you're being dishonest with your
own book. And that's what you guys
usually do. You guys hate the book. You
guys hate the Quran. I know. But it's
okay. This is what it says, ladies and
gentlemen. I said you guys hate the
Quran. You you as a Muslim, you hate the
Quran. You hate the book.
>> Why?
>> Because it goes against everything you
say.
>> No, you hate the Bible cuz you've
changed the Bible.
>> I got you. So, this is what it says
here, ladies and gentlemen. Chapter
39:4, it says, "If Allah intended to
take a son, he could have
he could have chosen from what he
creates and whatever he willed. Exalted
is he. He is Allah, the one, the
prevailing." So, is that metaphorical or
does Allah actually say if he wanted to,
he could have a son?
>> I'm telling you one more time. It's mate
for
>> All right, take your mate for in the
comment section.
>> Okay.
>> Off the stage.
>> I was I don't even know what that would
be a metaphor for in the first place.
Like, it didn't make any sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Guys, you won't last long if
you're dishonest. If you're dishonest
and you are um you know, you just
playing you just playing games with us
and you playing games with your own
book, you're not going to last long.
You're not going to last long at all.
Your Quran just said that Allah could
have a son if he wanted to. If you're
going to say it's a mit for, then you're
going to have to demonstrate how in the
context. Guy's just lying. Just throw
metaphor anywhere. Oh, it's a metaphor.
Get out of here. All right, let's try